how's it going it's matt go tagging
tutorials another video in the car
following up following up from my
previous one and another topic I want to
talk about that seems to confuse a lot
of people you see a lot of different
terms for the job description or for the
profession of of a software developer
software engineer software lead software
tech lead software everything I just
want to clarify what some of them sort
of mean at least to me as far as I can
best tell and correct me if I'm wrong
and I you know I'm always open to learn
more and anybody that watches this
channel is probably looking to learn
more too because that's kind of what
this is all about I'm riffing here so
I'm not looking up sources and putting
this together if I really butcher
something that badly sorry I'll try to
correct it if it's that bad but for the
most part we're just going with it here
so that's I'm gonna touch a few
definition specifically software
engineer software designer software
development
those three are the ones you hear most
I guess Architects in there to hear
architect a lot I guess there's always
the web text thrown in there to like
you'll see a web stack engineer and full
stack engineer front-end designer things
along those nature things along that
nature so okay well typically I feel
like if you're labeled an engineer if
you have engineer or architect that
means you are building new technologies
and tools from the ground up which means
you're coming up with your own data
structures putting them together
interfacing it that to me is more along
the Engineering architecting that is
really difficult it's
it's way more difficult than say what a
software designer would do a software
designer would be doing something more
along the lines of using tools that are
already built and then kind of just
putting them together to make another
new thing or an interface to something
so that way you're using technologies
and other tools that people have already
built and tested and you're just hooking
them up basically and that is the
easiest way to make software and it's
probably the best way to make software
don't be mistaken because engineering
and architecting well you know I guess
you could say you're architecting if
you're using tools to but if you're
engineering tools you know this just
goes to show that these titles really
don't mean anything you really have to
see a list of credentials and things
someone's worked on to really understand
what they're good at these titles are
hard hard to really get a read on about
what they really mean but this is kind
of also what I feel they should mean so
if a if someone is designing something
they're often just coming up with how it
should work and then connecting pieces
and where it fits almost like Legos so
that's really easy with web development
I'm sure a lot of you already kind of
know you can get frameworks and just
hook up things and put your own data and
it just works and it's like hey I'm a
software developer now and this is kind
of true you are some of it not to say
that that's easy a lot of that stuff is
still quite difficult it takes a lot of
a lot of knowledge to know what you need
to do next you can follow the toriel's
only so far before
you know you get to an area where you're
like well I can't find the answer to
this question what do I do
and that's where things could get more
difficult and is often the limit for
software developers because the next
step is engineering your own solutions
and that is way harder way way harder I
know I've already said that but it is
it is a whole nother realm like to hook
up a bunch of things that are already
built you basically just need to follow
the guides follow directions and just
kind of follow a list of things to do
and you can you can pretty much get
things done that way but when you're
engineering there's nothing like that
you can find occasional help yeah you
can often find documentation on how
these things work but putting them
together in the correct way is totally
up to you managing how the memory works
is totally up to you
managing memory in a way where an
operating system can page it properly is
up to you and if you mess it up no one's
really going to tell you people are just
gonna get crashes and they're gonna get
stack overflows and stuff and you'll
find out about it later then you've got
to go reanalyze what you built and
engineer a better solution when you're
just hooking up things that have already
been tested and everybody uses you can't
really mess it up and if you do you just
go look up the documentation on it like
the best practices and follow those and
you can build talk to her that way that
is I will say the easiest and most
gratifying way to build software well
for most people some people really get a
lot of get a lot of engineering their
own solutions but the problem with that
is is most things have been done before
and you can usually find a tool or some
API library to handle it for you and you
can save a lot of time that way because
if your engineering your own solution
let's just hype a lot hypothetically say
that it's going to take three months for
you to develop
a piece of something or a tool to
automate your level design or something
like that it's gonna take three months
or you could go go look at some API
that's already built that's already been
well tested and maybe it's even
open-source and you can spend a couple
days learning the ins and outs of how to
hook everything up maybe a week at the
most
and then you're good you're good you
didn't have to put in all the effort of
designing a brand new thing and you know
three months is a lot of time and it's
probably going to be more than that
that's it just really depends on what
you're trying to build you can build and
how big it is how much help you have and
then it might not even work right and
you might be right back to the drawing
board so that's the reason why you would
want to just use other people's tools
and just be a software developer or a
software designer and not an engineer
engineers are way more rare architects
are way more rare you don't see too many
of them and their pay is much higher and
that's the reason why because they're
they're breaking new ground usually when
they're designing something it's because
it hadn't been done to the
specifications that is needed by whoever
wants it need the company need the
person who's developing their own thing
so it's already been done you might as
well use what's available to you save
everyone the headache in time so I hope
this answers a lot of questions about
those different terms and maybe what you
should put on on your resume or CV or
whatever it is and how to kind of
interpret them and also to take them
with a grain of salt because sometimes
people just put titles up and they don't
actually really think about what it
means there's like a sounds good let's
put that let's put that there maybe they
put in software engineer when they
really want a software developer or a
software designer developer is kind of
vague too because what kind of software
you develop me you know that it doesn't
really answer that question if you're
just hooking up some API is making
things work
it's not the same as being able to
design new stuff from the ground up
successfully it's way different and they
could both be hold software developer so
really got a look at people's
credentials what they've completed in
the past you have questions about it
asking for other people who have worked
on their project and and consult with
them because a lot of times you just
want somebody that's gonna get the job
done right you know from from a company
or a recruiters standpoint you want
someone that can get the job done and
the greatest way to measure whether
someone can do a job or not is if
they've done it successfully before and
the only way to find out that is to get
references not everybody is honest when
they're getting hired people talk
themselves up as they kind of must to
get the job sometimes so as a as someone
doing the hiring you got to watch out
for that and that makes a lot of people
really annoyed a lot of potential
employees and wait because they know
they can do it but the person that's
going to hire them doesn't necessarily
believe that they can and it's it's a
chance it's a risk for them but if you
want to prove to the person that might
be hiring you that it's not a risk or
not a chance you can give good
references and say hey contact my
whoever and ask them about Project X or
what if your project projects name is in
that way they can they can call them
they can verify and maybe you'd want
several because you know you can
people always do that thing where they
like hey but then when I have a
recruiter call you and they're looking
for reference just be a good reference
you know that happens too so there's a
lot of angles here to look out for with
these terms and it's just something you
got to be aware of and it's not
something that's immediately obvious
until you're in the field for a while
and start so I've seen how people kind
of treat treat things it's it's where I
look weird it's weird a lot of stuffs
weird all right that's gonna do it for
this video hope you guys all have a
wonderful day and let me know your
comments below